donald trump será oficialmente el
candidato a las presidenciales de 2020
cuando finalice la convención nacional
republicana este jueves el evento inicia
este lunes y se realizará mayormente de
manera virtual en principio estaba
planeado en la ciudad de jacksonville
florida no obstante el avance de la
pandemia de kobe 19 hizo que trump se
diera y cancelará los eventos por lo que
el grueso de la convención se realizará
de forma virtual sin embargo en
charlotte carolina del norte se
mantienen las reuniones de negocios
previas y alrededor de 300 delegados de
todo el país estarán en la ciudad para
la confirmación del candidato los
asistentes deben presentar una prueba
negativa de coronavirus para ingresar al
lugar importar tapabocas lo que haremos
será dejar claro que eeuu es un mejor
lugar hoy que antes de las elecciones
del presidente trump hay muchas cosas
por resaltar asuntos internacionales la
economía va mejor a pesar del cob y hay
muchos problemas sí pero también muchas
soluciones el evento en el que
intervendrán varios representantes
republicanos así como su hija ivanka
trump su yerno jared kushner y la ex
embajadora ante la onu nikki haley entre
otros
se produce tras la convención demócrata
en la que joe biden fue confirmado como
su contrincante en esa ocasión el
mandatario rompió la tradición y criticó
en repetidas ocasiones al
exvicepresidente acusándolo de querer
acabar con el país
actualmente el mandatario se encuentra
ocho puntos porcentuales abajo de su
rival principalmente a causa del manejo
de la pandemia y de las recientes
protestas contra el racismo que ha
vivido el país